you know the series a more perfect union
we aim to show that what unites us is
far greater than what divides us this
morning we have the inspiring story of
one woman's grueling quest to complete
100 marathons in 100 days after a major
setback people around the world rallied
behind her in a unique way
Niki batiste is here with her journey
her motivation and her struggle Niki
good morning good morning John 100
marathons and 100 days seems like an
impossible task both mentally and
physically but one woman backed by a
community of strangers helped change the
conversation from impossible to
remarkable I've run a marathon a hundred
marathons on 100 days is insane yeah I
wish you told me that a hundred days ago
forty eight-year-old Australian native
Mina ghuli wants people to know she
didn't set out to run 2,620 miles for
the exercise when I tell people I'm
running a hundred marathons instantly
they think I'm running a hundred miles
because I like running and you like
running I kidding it's like a hundred
marathon is a hundred days of pain it's
been running in some of the most extreme
places on the planet from the ROC and
Uzbekistan to Australia which was
incredibly hot the 100 marathon
challenge was born out of what ghuli
calls necessity she is the founder and
CEO of thirst a nonprofit created to
help battle water scarcity around the
globe by the year 2050 the United
Nations says as many as 5.7 billion
people could be living in these areas
without easy access to one of life's
most essential resources most people
have no idea so I wanted to run because
I wanted to make saving water famous
ghuli began her journey at the New York
City Marathon this past November and
continued to log her miles in some of
the most iconic and remote locations on
earth winding her way through six
continents all spots that have suffered
dangerous water shortages Ghoulies
ambition for this project has scuttled
her to the far reaches of the planet but
after 62 days her body hit the brakes
what happened on day 62 had quite severe
pain in my leg the pain had got so bad
that I couldn't walk my team had to
carry me into the car took me to the
hospital and I was diagnosed with having
a fracture in my right femur what are
you feeling in that moment you're in the
middle of this unbelievable journey I
felt like I'd let everybody down I felt
that I had let down all the people whose
stories I wanted to tell I felt that I
had let down the water crisis I felt I'd
let down my planet and then you got on
your social media so actually what
happened was sitting in the hospital
literally outside the scanning room the
doctors were sitting in front of me and
messages started to come through on my
phone and then it was people who I
didn't know who offered to donate
distance to the campaign we've had
people on all seven continents including
Antarctica running for us running from
for me for water whether they were
literally helping push goli toward our
goal or running on their own strangers
from around the world collectively
completed nearly 20,000 miles in only 38
days all culminating back in New York
City for the 99th and 100th marathons
where her unthinkable mission began what
is the support from around the world
meant to you the support has inspired me
to keep going even when I thought always
lost
it's inspired me to be a better person
to stand up and to be prepared to make a
difference and more importantly it's
shown me that even though each one of us
is an individual together we can make a
huge change
[Applause]
doctors advised Meena against running so
many marathons citing her age and
physical health in all strangers from
around the world ran 748 marathons and
Mina's name far surpassing the remaining
38 she needed to complete her goal and
isn't she so inspiring every single day
- Wow and you know what it's like
yourself to run a marathon I'm impressed
with that knee thank you and having run
one I can't imagine even running exactly
two in a row so kudos to her and she's
she's healing she's healing she still
has five months till she can run again
but she brought a lot of attention to it
cause yes doing that inspired a lot of
people thank you